if you want to know what a complete sham
what a fraudulent grotesque perversion
of reality the White House briefings
have become you should see what happened
today the low IQ would ask Presbytery
brought in a bunch of TV actors to stand
there so she could promote a TV show for
some reason why are we doing this again
she never really explained mental health
day or something none of them were
doctors
but at the same time she was promoting a
TV show The White House Presbytery
refused to take questions from actual
reporters first on that list would be
our friend Simon atiba of Today News
Africa so today a team just got
frustrated and called out the White
House Press Secretary for ignoring his
actual questions for months watch what
happened next
[Music]
Russia this
don't make assumptions about what the
rest of us do mind your manners when
you're in here if you have a problem you
bring it up afterwards what has just
occurred this last 10 15 minutes is
unacceptable
so we're either going to continue the
briefing or we can just end the briefing
right here
outrageous doesn't even describe what we
just played for you so here you have the
White House Press Secretary whose job it
is to answer questions from journalists
on behalf of the entire American
population hijacking the event to
promote a TV show
and then screaming at a guy who wants
his questions answered and then the
other shills in the room don't take the
side of their fellow journalist but take
the side of the lady at the front to
whom they are actually beholden and try
and shut down Simon attiba who did that
glissa partial list that would include
Jeff Mason of Reuters who should be
ashamed Brian Karam of CNN
Associated Press correspondent Zeke
Miller
he even apologized to the Presbytery
leader in the press conference they
again should be ashamed of themselves in
previous generations of reporters would
have turned on them really are taking
her side she's a liar your job is not to
suck up to power it's to serve your
viewers and readers by getting to the
truth
but instead they piled on Simon attiva
really the most revealing moment maybe
ever in the White House Press Room we
are honored now to be joined by Simon
Akiba himself
Simon thank you so much for coming on
we're really glad to have you what what
prompted you seem very frustrated there
what prompted your exchange with the
press secretary
yes thank you doctor thank you for
having me on your show I'm grateful you
know the first amendment protects the
freedom of speech the press and assembly
and the right to petition your
government to seek redress and that
First Amendment says that I have the
right to ask questions to do my job and
the press secretary doesn't need to like
me date me marry me have two black
children with me she doesn't need all
that she doesn't even need to like my
accent doesn't need to like what I look
like where I come from they look down on
me they don't respect the First
Amendment and so what has been happening
in the White House is in the past seven
months I've done all the right things
I've not been called on I've gone to her
office to seek a meeting she said that
she will meet with me next year I've
sent questions about the Nigerian
election about you know the problems
challenges in Africa and and they've not
called on me even has the the vice
president is going to Africa even as the
first lady Jill Biden went to Africa
even when they received 50 African
leaders for the U.S African Summit in
Washington DC the guy who covers the
White House the African guy who covers
the White House is looked down upon in
the greatest country in the world in the
most advanced country where freedom of
speech is protected it's a shame what
happened today one of the guys that you
showed there now Brian he was kicked out
of the the waca because he became
violent in the Rose Garden it's a
disgrace it's very violent it he attacks
many people he's a shame what happened
to me today it's a total disgrace and is
happening in the Biden White House and
and and you know when it happens to Jim
Acosta of CNN because they respect him
he's white he works for CNN and black
I'm African I don't have money they look
down on me I don't have the
opportunities that they have and and and
they don't treat me the same way I need
to do my job the freedom of speech and
the press in the U.S allows me to do my
job and that's the only thing that I'm
trying to do and they are stonewalling
me trying to help Karen jump here and
and and and it's a shame
the fact that Jeff Mason and the rest
who should be ashamed of himself took
the White House side against you is
really the most one of the most awful
things I've ever seen I was shocked by
the cynical as I am and I appreciate
you're coming on tonight you seem
unbowed seminate but we are rooting for
you thank you
thank you for having me
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight